einmal einen ganz normalen café die
schönheit corpus dass die maschinen so
was kann
sojamilch nein danke das büro ist
interessant worden ja oder nein mein
vater war ist ja sowas von oldschool ihr
wisst ja mit den ganzen schienen aus
kurven nur ums news sonst ja habe ich
selber macht digitaler kunst kurs was
man in einem monat soll er kann geld ja
mittlerweile kannst du am computer alles
machen und wenn wir jetzt noch den
ganzen papierkram digitalisieren kann
dann bringen am tischtennisplatten teil
aber mir sein herz nicht hier um über
mich zu sprechen
mein lieber herr bandle wie lange können
wir uns jetzt schon 30 sekunden genau
und ich habe sie gebeten hier
vorbeizuschauen weil ich gesehen habe
dass mein vater ihnen nie so eine
berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung angedreht
angeboten hat ja doch angesprochen haben
wir schon drüber aber ich bin
schuhverkäufer das ist nicht direkt
hochrisiko branche dina so wenig wie
versicherungsmakler müssen so wirklich
viel passiert ist sagt sie er so schnell
dass sie gar nicht schauen und diese
vision ihrem schuhladen herr bundle
stellen sie eine diesmal vor eine frau
betritt ihr geschäft ja sie kommt zu
schuhbändel kreativer name jedenfalls
visualisieren sie das
die frau kommt und probiert einen
heimsieg liegen hinter der frau machen
gerade das riemchen zu und in diesem
moment muss die frau niesen und haut er
nannte absatz mitten ins auge
sie fallen nach hinten und audi kaputt
rücken gebrochen berufsunfähig und es
sie übers ohr verpackungspapier am boden
und rutschen raus und ich liebte in
richtung ausgang und knallen mit dem
kopf in die glastür die glastür
zerspringt und sie sahen paniert mit
splitter schädelbasisbruch
gedächtnisverlust sie verbluten
berufsunfähig
oder sie wollen ganz oben aus dem regal
an schulter trug und in diesem moment ja
vielleicht wirklich bis zur
berufsunfähig und wie das besser werden
safety first gute entscheidung sehr gute
entscheidung der bahn
die hoppers vorbereiten zu müssen
eigentlich nur noch darunter
unterschreiten
die ist am bildstock super chance doch
oder also auf ihre future heißt
[Musik]
es ist was passiert
sie überlegt man das nun mit der
berufsunfähigkeit
ich glaube das ist nichts für mich er
ist empfehlen
danke
[Applaus]